hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and several
years ago I watched a documentary about
philosophers called examined life there
aren't that many documentaries about
philosophers and it was it was just a
very enjoyable thought-provoking kind of
experience he had these philosophers out
there in the world they weren't just
behind their desks in their offices or
lecturing in a hallway they were out
there in cars on the streets doing
things and then talking about the
relationship between philosophy and
practice and the real world so I was
interested to find out that the
documentarian who made this film Astra
Taylor has recently been working on the
idea of democracy she has both a new
another documentary that just came out
called what is democracy and she has a
new book that has just come out called
democracy may not exist but we'll miss
it when it's gone I think that's almost
exactly right you know as soon as you
say well democracy blah blah so many
people say we don't live in a democracy
either you know we live in a republic or
they try to say well we don't really
have the voice that we should to truly
make it a democracy and so forth and so
Astra is saying yes that's right but
there's still good things about
democracy that we should think about try
to make them better rather than just
despairing that it can't be done so she
goes all the way back to ancient Greece
you know Plato and Aristotle our
founding philosophers were notoriously
against democracy they didn't really
like the idea but Athens was definitely
the touchstone for the flowering of
democracy subsequently in the Western
world at least and Rome as those of you
who listen to mindscape know from my
conversation with Ed Watts Rome was more
of a republic than a democracy it's
interesting to compare those and it's
interesting too moving forward to the
present day where we have technology and
we live in these huge societies where
the relationship between individual
voters and what their governments do
grows increasingly tenuous so democracy
is on the one hand very very important
to us on the other hand is taken for
granted a little bit and we should
promote democracy I think but also we
need to keep it on its toes we need to
make sure that it's really doing what it
is there to do there's good questions to
ask about whether democracy is the right
thing to do
from a philosophical intellectual
viewpoint we should always be probing
whether we're on the right track so I
think that democracy is is a is a
fantastically important part of our
world yet something we don't actually
devote enough brain cells to really
thinking about in a deep way and I think
this conversation helps us do that in a
way that is also very entertaining
reminders of course this is a podcast so
you're welcome to go on to iTunes and
elsewhere and leave reviews of it we
also have a patreon account where you
can support mindscape we have ads coming
up but the patreon supporters will
certainly still get benefits for example
you get Ad free versions of the podcast
if you support on patreon and also we
get monthly ask me anything where you
can ask me any question and I will try
to answer it in a special podcast just
for patreon supporters so there's still
some motivation to go there with that I
think this is a wonderful conversation
that is both philosophically provocative
and very very relevant to how we live in
the world today so let's go
[Music]
Astra Taylor thanks so much for coming
on the mindscape podcast thanks for
having me
so I am familiar with some of your films
back in the day Dziedzic and the
examined life and these were about
philosophical topics pretty
straightforwardly right and here you are
with a new book out and also a new
documentary about democracy so why don't
you tell us a little about your journey
from slightly more abstract ivory tower
philosophizing to a little bit more down
in the political mess kind of thinking
and and activism yeah it is you know it
seems like they might be unrelated but
into me they really are I have always
been someone who wanted to marry theory
and practice so you know I could never
quite become a full-time philosopher
myself only be a scholar because I
always wanted to experiment with my
ideas you know and especially if they
relate to ethics and politics and the
question that's that old Socratic
question of how should we live well you
can't decide that on your own you can't
really figure that out definitively on
your own you know and so then the
question for me has been okay well how
do i how do I build this kind of life
where I get to engage with questions
philosophical questions theoretical
questions have a kind of life of the
mind and also well you know the life of
a person trying to to embody those
principles in some way so I do that
through through organizing and I do that
through through writing and I do that
through filmmaking so those films you
know Gigi jet came out 2005 so I was 25
examined life came out in 2008 and those
were the tagline of examine life was
philosophy is in the street right so
what I wanted to do with that was to
show the way these abstract ideas are
actually all around us they're built
into our environment they're there in
the space we inhabit and and and to
treat ideas with a bit of a reverence
and playfulness so I have all these
philosophers sort of traveling through
different places and even you know
rowing a boat or walking through a
garbage dump and trying to also you know
in a way express my own enthusiasm for
philosophy and to share it with people
you know and to share it in a way that
didn't intimidate them I hope you know I
wanted to make it fun and engaging um
but then I I sort of felt after example
knife came out like you know this isn't
I didn't dream of being a filmmaker um
you know i-i-i again it's you know I
want I want to bring these ideas I
wanted to kind of go the next step which
for me was actually trying to get more
involved in politics and organizing so
that's so so when you look at it that
way then what is democracy which is the
name of the documentary film and the
companion book democracy may not exist
but we'll miss it when it's gone it's
kind of it's actually a very clear kind
of next step and I I will say this about
it you know democracy in my mind as I
understand it and I say this in the
preface demands philosophy democracy is
intellectually hard that's a quote from
Daniel Allen
classicist and who I who I interviewed
and and it's hard because at the center
of democracy is an abstraction the
people right the people doesn't just
exist like a fact out there in the world
that we can point to and so already you
have this abstraction and how do you
have an abstraction deciding things and
making ethical decisions and governing
itself so you know philosophy is sort of
part and parcel of democratic life and
and we hinted this in our media when we
talk about deliberation or debate or
even this whole conversation happening
now about facts the truth but I think
it's I think it's like you know so so
democracy is theory in practice always
it's like we have to reflect and act and
reflect and act in and so the film is an
attempt and the book or both attempts to
just sort of bring that philosophical
dimension into into focus and I my my
feeling is it can help us at this moment
a political crisis but other people
might not agree that's democracy I do
you think yeah exactly I think that uh
because we're so most of us in this
country you know grew up in a democracy
we tend to forget or at least
underestimate how philosophically
radical this idea is and the idea that
just everybody has a voice or should
we head of has a voice in how the
society is run certainly comes along
with a whole bunch of presuppositions
about you know who deserves to have
power and things like that so philosophy
should be part of that it makes sense to
me yeah and you know but what's
interesting so that both of the projects
go back to the founding text of the
Western philosophical tradition Plato's
Republic
yeah and it's it's a founding text of
Western philosophy and it's interesting
because it's aunt it's anti democracy
this moment when Athenian democracy is
in decline and Plato is saying he's he's
issuing a very powerful critique of
democracy in a nutshell he basically
says you know democracy marginalizes the
wise love you know his definition of a
philosopher was someone who loves wisdom
and and the virtuous and he had reason
to think that because the democracy had
put his his mentor Socrates to death
right they said hey you can either be
exiled or you can drink the hemlock and
he was too proud and they drank that
hemlock so you know there's always been
this this concern it's it's a concern
that's ancient that that well the people
aren't philosophical they aren't wise
and so I think you see this in my work
again and again where I'm saying well we
have to create a philosophical public
you know this is also you know the it's
also about democratizing not just access
to knowledge or information or facts but
you know confidence that one can
participate in a certain kind of
conversation and and precisely because
that abstract reflection is demanded by
the political system that we we say we
have we say we aspire to so we better do
it like there's no other way there's no
way around you can't have democracy and
not aspire to have a philosophical
public because democracy has no there is
no barrier to entry right it shouldn't
be based on the color of your skin how
much money is in your bank account or
what school you went to it's like sorry
we can rub it right well you know you're
preaching to the converted here at X
gave a central this is part of what I'm
trying to do with the podcast right is
talk to people about big ideas in a way
that is
is made possible by this new medium so
just before I really do when I get
mostly in the democracy but I have to
ask sort of a strategic question about
writing books versus making
documentaries right you know what how do
you visualize those two very separate
but related activities most people would
do one or the other but you try to get
both going yeah and then I want to ask
you a question because that's what I
always I always like to do so I mean to
me to me I think I'm I'm medium agnostic
and medium curious you know we have all
these different we have all these
different mediums and you know I'm not a
Marshall McLuhan I like the medium is
the message and so each medium is but
there is some truth to that like
different mediums have different
affordances different capacities they
they conjure different effects well in
different audiences right in different
audiences right so for me it depends you
know I see organizing as a medium so
when you are building an institution
that's a medium through which human
beings interact and and perceive the
world so it just sort of depends on what
what has captured my attention film you
know is more akin to a podcast in the
sense that it's you know it's it's
direct its it has an emotional quality
so you know because my films are mostly
made up of interviews with people and so
there's the words that they're literally
speaking but then there's all of their
their expressive aspects you know and
and whether you empathize with them
whether you like them whether they're
charismatic or not I get a lot of
comments on the podcast about the fact
that it's audio only and I'm sympathetic
to this because it really does matter to
see people talk but you know so far I
don't have the technological
capabilities of that but maybe sometime
in the future that will happen well it's
funny because I often think God podcasts
are great because you don't have to see
someone so it's like what if the
backgrounds ugly or what if you know
it's raining outside you know brushing
their nose in an awkward way I mean you
know then it all that matters is what
said but you know even at film my phone
was an hour and 45 minutes or so
and you know but if you transcribed it
it wouldn't make rational sense because
there are these leaps that film allows
and also it wouldn't be very long it
would be like a academic book chapter or
something like that so the so the film
allows for me to give space to other
people to honor them to be interested in
them to kind of actually focus press to
the audience my own curiosity about
other people which i think is important
which is what kind of what you're doing
on this podcast you're saying hey you
know I might be this amazing physicist
but I'm so curious about people I still
want to ask questions and I think asking
questions and having that curiosity I'm
almost as like interested in having that
be part of my propaganda like we should
be curious about others as the more kind
of traditional political takeaways of
the film and then a book you know you
get to you get to write at length you
get to have footnotes all of these
things all of these details that would
just weigh a movie down you know we
can't stop and say hey check this page
of this obscure text Machiavelli or you
know Madison or Marx or whoever so
that's where I get to be more didactic I
also get to say more I get to kind of
express my point of view more so you
know the mediums have different they're
they're they're different depending on
what it is I'm trying to communicate I
when I go speak at colleges and and
young people come up to me and say you
know I really want to be a filmmaker I'm
always slightly befuddled because to me
it's like well that's just a shell or a
vessel what is it you want to
communicate yeah yeah yeah good point
right you know cuz it's like there's
lots of terrible books in the world
there's lots of terrible movies it's
like to me it's the message the story
the thing that you want to share with
other humans yeah because I think that
at heart your your essence is not a
filmmaker your intellectual / activist
right and yeah I remember when cuz I'm a
science consultant sometimes for movies
and so I got to meet Ridley Scott who
was thinking of making a movie of the
forever war and I don't think it it has
happened maybe it will never happen but
so it's based on a novel already so
there's some plot but there didn't there
was no screenplay at the time when we
met with him but he clearly in his mind
had certain scenes already perfectly
mapped out visually
and it was very clear from talking to
him that that's what he was about right
making these wonderful visual moments
and then the plot whatever okay we'll
figure that out you know what happens in
movie comes second I think that's
perfectly okay but it's a very different
thing than someone who is just about the
message or the substance and then finds
different media in which to express it
yeah I think it's really different I
mean you know there's and and I I'm very
charmed and interest in people who are
visual first you know or say I had this
image of a girl walking through a field
of sunflowers I mean I feel make her
friend literally said that it was like
wow that was enough beautiful thing to
make other other to have other art forms
but again it's just it's not me I was
interested in you you know because I
think you know I write about this a
little bit in the chapter on education
in the book but you know there are kinds
of expertise that you know you're you
know you're almost the cliché of a
person with knowledge right being this
theoretical physicist right Prudential
and so forth right right
and yet and so what what but yet you're
still open to this idea of democracy as
this as this is an intellectual pursuit
that needs to include everybody I mean
I'm just curious if that that just feels
is that just something that is almost
like an instinctual sense of trust of
other people or well yeah no I mean this
is definitely something that I want to
talk about so let's talk about it yeah
democracy one of the radical parts of it
is the idea that everyone not only has a
voice but isn't in some sense ideally
equal right one person one vote of
course there are distortions to that
from power and money and so forth but
that's the ideal and it it is there's
clearly a worry that some people don't
really deserve as much of a voice if
you're sort of we these days we would
call it technocratic right if you think
there's a right answer to what
government should do at all times isn't
it the case that the smart people are
more likely to find the right answer but
I always thought it is never very hard
to me I just thought that was the wrong
way of thinking about how a government
works and and the purpose of democracy
the purpose is to make sure everyone's
interests are represented right it I
feel bad because I'm very
middle-of-the-road about these things I
like the idea of a represe
democracy in which people vote and they
expressed their interest by doing that
and then the representatives gained
expertise in various ways and implement
the policies the best way possible
it seems very you know bushwa so forth I
think that if when that system works
very well it's the right thing to do and
so I think that the right place for
expertise is at the level where we've
already recommended sorry we've already
elected our representatives and those
people ideally we'll go to the experts
to find out what's going on yeah I mean
I'm not I think I say something I don't
want to be involved in every decision
right I mean you know and and and that
you know expertise is a is a is an
essential component I think when when
that becomes abstracted still above like
okay well let's just let Technic rats
govern or the experts govern it's not
it's not then it becomes more of a
problem right oh no absolutely become a
self-serving you know a self-serving
group and there may be there's no
accountability so you know the you know
it's funny I wouldn't describe myself as
middle-of-the-road but I'm always trying
to find the complexities or find the
balance and things or you know we're
we're you know so and I think expertise
is a really interesting one because you
know it's it's and there's something
undemocratic about it because absolutely
yeah an expert at everything and yet we
desperately need it in a society it's
complicated as well I think it's a huge
worry I think that one of the sets of
people who reject democracy implicitly
or explicitly are people or the masters
of the universe who think that they know
what's best right and think that
basically they should have the voice and
in some sense you know I had a podcast
interview with Yasha Monk about liberal
democracy and how it's failing and and
his point was you know the word liberal
is not just there to make it a longer
phrase it really means something it
means a certain set of protections for
people and populist movements can be
very democratic right as long as they
define democratic in the right way and
and his theory is that a lot of the
attraction of populist movements is that
democracy is seen to not be working in
places like Europe where the European
Union has put so much power into
technocratic elites right so that the
person on the street thinks nothing that
I do has nem
act on what the government does and I
think that you know I'm not an expert I
don't know whether that's true or not
but I do agree it would be bad if that
were the right case well I mean there's
you know to bring it back to the United
States there doesn't do quite a bit of
evidence that regular people don't
actually have any say over the policies
so there was the famous study that
became known as the oligarchy study but
you know I think they what is that I'm
not familiar with you the political
scientists were jyllands and Paige it
was I think this was maybe 2014 I feel
like time is speeding up they crunched
the numbers and they said you know
regular citizens have virtually no
impact over policy you know it's yeah
it's big donors I mean it's and again
these are things people know Maher guts
even if they haven't read the social
science research true and you know I
think that that's part of that's part of
the frustration you know yasha Monk is
an interesting example because I read
his book and I was very surprised to see
my name mentioned as a populist what I
had written a book I mean I'm sorry I'd
written an article where I said well hey
part of the problem in it was for the
New Republic which is a bastion of
liberalism actually but but I said the
point of it was basically that there in
the wake of the election Donald Trump
there's a big anti-democratic urge
coming from elites actually right the
sense that the people had made a
terrible mistake there was actually this
resurgence of interest in Plato's
Republic
you know maybe democracy does always
devolve into journey and I'm understand
why that was happening but but my sense
was you know my point was that you know
the problem is in my view that we
haven't democratized that enough right
right that there's still there's still
there's still work to be done let's not
let's not name democracy as the problem
let's fight over what we mean by
democracy and democratization let's look
at the concentration of wealth and power
let's try to look at the sources of
people's frustrations and address those
and and so I I think I come at it you
know from it from a different angle
because I still I I'm where some people
are very worried right now about what
about a sort of populist threat and a
sort of you know the the question almost
of like the tyranny of the majority
right that the people and their unruly
passions so again the Plato thing I'm
more I'm more concerned about the points
of minority veto power in our political
system right now in a way that
progressive progressive desires are
actually being thwarted because if you
look for example there is rising
xenophobia I mean there's there's
horrible things happening right now at
the border and there are very scary
scary trends not just in the US but in
Europe and Beyond and yet polls show
that actually Americans have more
positive use of immigration they've had
since 1965 Americans want gun control
Americans all sorts of progressive
forward-looking things and they're
blocked because of these again these
veto points structures of minority power
the Supreme Court's going to be worse on
this moving forward the Senate is also a
minority Rhian sort of institution right
in the sense that less populous states
have disproportionate power the
electoral college obviously is what
really gave us Donald Trump as the
president so that's where I'm always
trying to temper this this condemnation
of the people and say well hold on what
are the structures that are actually
yeah blocking the more progressive will
well it's interesting so I think that
the what I got from talking in yasha was
the idea that populism is sort of its
self conception is very democratic but
it's always at the cost of shrinking the
circle of the people who actually count
as the ones who get to vote right so
like excluding foreigners and so forth
or buying art yeah I mean it's
interesting you know this is you know
all all definitions are unsettled you
know and so for me I also see again to
go back to the question of democracy so
what what you know we can always joke
because people bring up issues of
populism and liberalism and the Cuban
A's for my film especially it almost
like okay yes I can my even my next even
more market unmarketable film will be
what is some but you know to begin with
the titular question of myself you know
what is democracy and and it's I'd like
the I like to go back to the ancient
Greek
roots of the word and and I think it's
very important that it be clear that the
Greeks didn't give us the practice of
democracy or of people engaging and
trying to have power over their own
lives but they give us this word and I
think it's a really great word and it's
the demos the people have kratos power
or rule hold power grasp power meant to
sort of hold on to something and and so
this question of who the people are is
constitutive of democracy itself it's
not it's not a populist aberration to be
fighting over how we define this it's
something that we have to kind of face
head-on it's a hat is begging to buy the
idea of democracy right who are the
people who have this will it's it's just
it's just part of our struggle and so it
is true that there's this you know you
can call it a small populist tendency to
say you know to do a kind of us or them
and exclude immigrants and foreigners
but then you know the but as I said it's
also just a problem of democracy it's up
how do we define the demos how do we
define the polity how do you how do we
define the we and and make that we
accountable so I think there's you know
this is a problem that that we have to
face and it gets really it's a really
thorny thorny not just philosophical
issue because people's lives are at
stake
yeah we've shown that demos can can
radically expand and it can radically
contract and and we have to figure we I
think the point is to recognize it
actually how things are today are not
set in stone and that's what we have to
always remember to like have to keep an
imaginative flame alive yeah you know I
mean you can't do democracy without well
this question of who counts right who is
in the demos who's who's a person you
can't just say everybody right because
there's no democracy ever that has given
people the right to vote the moment
they're born
for example we exclude children
historically we've excluded women and
and various groups I had an interesting
podcast interview with Ed Watts the
historian about the decline of the Roman
Republic it was eventually replaced by
an empire but it succeeded very well for
500 years and part of its success was
whenever Rome would conquer another
country they would very quickly give
them the
to vote in Roman elections and that
seems a little weird to us today but it
worked really well for them at the time
it it just as a reminder there's no
clearly right and wrong way to draw
these lines well it's interesting
because the empires have often done that
right there at the the method the Roman
Empire's great example was just like
okay fine now you're a citizen right
similarly you are being assimilated
essentially by us and democracies do
have an unappealing tendency towards the
opposite which is to exclude and so you
know to contrast Rome with Greece Greece
was expands was extremely exclusive
because you had to have two citizen
parents at a certain point they said oh
actually you know no you see only have
to have the one citizen parent that
notice from when they made it that the
mother also had to be a citizen so so
made that bloodline you know even more
constrained and if you look at you know
I talked about this in the book in the
chapter on inclusion and exclusion that
for example Canada so I'm Canadian but I
grew up in the American South but when
Canada was part of the British Empire
you know where that constellation it was
more open to immigrants and then when it
separated itself and had control of its
citizenship laws it started to become
more exclusive so there's some troubling
humility and then they were like behold
on what is Canadian nests I mean and so
in this process of even inventing what
it meant to be Canadian they started to
close the door to people from other
parts of the world so this is it's it's
it's definitely one of Democracies least
appealing features my point I think I
think what makes it really hard is that
right now it's difficult just given the
state of the world to imagine forms of
constructing Adiemus or people that
aren't really negative because we're
living in a moment where the exclusions
are founded on really troubling
histories
histories of racism histories of
colonization you know you know
immigration law is designed to exploit
labor forces right so then you know
we're not really in a position where we
can ask well hold on when is when is
when is setting the boundary of a
community actually ethical you know when
do people need to be involved in a
decision or I mean because because when
we I mean on the one hand we have to do
that but on the other hand it's hard to
separate the fact that we've been really
nasty about these things going yeah like
right now exclusions are predicated
predicated on terrible things like race
this arbitrary fact of where you were
born and you know or they were based on
gender and sexuality you know exclusion
it does not have a pretty history you
remind us that citizen only gave women
the vote in like 1971 or something like
that yeah right I mean this is and this
is all really really recent so I think
the thing is you know under what and yet
you know I agree we can't imagine
democracy including 8 9 10 billion
people because that would be being
incoherent so you know I think we but
there has to we have to wrestle with
this fact that at a certain point yeah
you do you do have to have you do have
to have boundaries and and I think for
me the solution is that we have to
create a more equal world where you know
in a world that is so terribly unequal
where the thing that determines the
quality of your life your life
expectancy is not what a hard worker you
are or how smart you are but just
basically where you were born were you
born Yeah right and your passport right
and you know and so we in a world like
that exclusion as a matter of life or
death in a more equal world it would it
would be a very very different calculus
and the fact is in a more equal world a
lot less people would want to move from
where they are you will so one of the
issues I wanted to ask about was the
relationship of democracy which we let's
let's put aside the idea that democracy
is not a good idea okay there are people
who think that but let's agree that
democracy is good but there's lots of
things that are good right equality and
liberty and justice and economic freedom
healthcare or whatever how
we do you include all those good things
in a definition of democracy or do we
try to slice it so that we can consider
all these virtues separately I don't
have a hard and fast answer to that I
think that's something that you know
every generation will have to reassess
because we have you know I think we have
shifting expectations and shifting
baselines so you know I think democracy
does demand by its definition by its
minimal definition of the people ruling
a baseline of equality right of
political equality yeah and I think that
you cannot have political equality under
conditions of intense economic
inequality I think that's a reasonable
claim that's one you have its work to
establish it and really convince people
yes and you know it's so controversial
to a lot of very powerful people and
maybe some less powerful people who are
aspired to having that yeah I think what
is the phrase that's like you know every
you know we all we all think we're gonna
be millionaires one day so we hold
political ideals for those incredibly
fabulously wealthy future selves um so I
think you know I think there is this I
think there there are some minimum
requirements you know should we separate
out these other values from from
democracy I mean you know I think we
have to we have to decide is we have to
decide well what are what are the values
that we are we're we are oriented
towards as a as a people so yeah maybe
they're separate but then they become
part of the Democratic project right
like you know it becomes sort of
implicit that well democracy well you
know in the phrase of the Constitution
right is the pursuit of happiness I'd
rather have it be just like well-being
her something like that but flourishing
yeah yeah our collective flourishing or
something like this sort of it's very
hard to have to just separate the the
ins from the from the means from the the
goal from the process and yet I do think
that that again
they always those values always have to
be assessed and reassessed yeah this is
you know we might aspire to things we
aspire to things obviously that you know
100 years ago
would've just been like well yeah what
are you what the hell are you people
aiming at her which make who are you
people a lot of you people are not
supposed to be in the people and 100
years from now what will that discussion
look like about us exactly the kind of
thing I like to think you know and you
spend your life and you know science
physics universe time but you know
sometimes I want to say you know even in
in our more mundane conception of time
but you know hopefully a hundred years
from now there will be new assumptions
and new aspirations that that make us
look backwards right yeah and that's
part of why I like the word democracy in
its vagueness because who the people are
is open for debate and how they rule is
also open to conversation and
transformation so I like that this
concept that we have this word we can
hold on to but we can also really
radically reinvent it oh yeah this was
impressed on me actually believe it or
not when I took a class in grad school
with John Rawls the political
philosopher and oh wow I've never met
mean that's you know that's Titan he was
yeah he was an amazing guy and actually
I always find it funny because he loved
cosmology and physics so I really never
got to talk to him about philosophy
because Hilly's want to talk about
cosmology whenever we chatted but he had
this he also you know his his motto was
justice as fairness and ordering a
society on the basis of fairness to
everyone and happily because this isn't
always true for great thinkers but he
lived by what he preached and he was the
fairest guy I have ever met
and one of his things was he had an
ongoing you know challenge if you can
find a logical flaw in his principles of
justice then you know he gives you a
hundred dollars or something like that
there and no one ever did right he you
know he he listened if you if you had a
proposal but one of the things was of
course these principles are having to do
with you know don't allow inequality
unless it benefits even the least off in
society you would you would come up with
something well what if there was an
epidemic and everyone was dying and you
had to you know do something like that
and he but he was very clear that he
meant his principles to apply to a well
ordered functioning healthy society
right and that was all precondition for
making any of this happen and I think
that even if you're not a rolls Ian
there's an underappreciated aspect of
democracy that that if not requires then
at least suggests that everyone should
have some minimal both economic and
political resources I think I mean I
think it does because you can't be again
if the democracy is people engaging in
ruling themselves if you are well you
know if you don't have them the minimum
subsistence yeah survive but also so
that you're you can't be sort of
terribly coerced right then you can't
engage in those in the in the processes
democracy requires and you know but this
is also this you know we take this as
common sense but different at different
moments in history people looked at this
in in different ways so for the ancient
Greeks you know there was a contempt of
of labour they associated leisure with
democracy with that freedom that space
to govern in fact they just learned that
the roots of the word school was
actually also had to do with sort of
free time right needed that time to
engage in the the learning to engage in
the sort of more elevated modes of life
which included being able to go to the
assembly and stuff like that so you know
and so there was a whole enslaved
laboring class and the United States was
also it is you know is a democracy that
was founded on unfreedom on slavery and
there was also a sense that you know
working people with just you know were
subjected to coercion not necessarily
sort of like free hold farmers who had
their own land that's why that the
yeoman farmer was this ideal but you
know people in the factories or or
slaves so there's this sense that labor
you know labor laboring people didn't
have what it didn't have what it takes
yeah I couldn't stand up so yeah just
wonderful scene in the film where you're
interviewing these
school kids in Miami I think it was and
you asked them a you bring up the
possibility or the prospect that they
could have a voice in how the school was
run and they point out that when they
try to ask for things their privileges
can be taken away right there vending
machines can be taken away and this
actually happens and part of that of
course there's a surface of saying like
you this is why kids don't get to
participate in democracy but then you
think about it and go like oh wait a
minute maybe I'm the kid and this in
this parable right like maybe all of us
are subject to having our privileges
taken away in some way I really like
that and I'm happy that's how you
interpret it cuz that's how I see it too
I mean I think the the scene and it's
interesting because the film and the
book are companions but they're not it's
not there it's not like the book is a
transcript of the film and yet the kids
live in both mediums they got to be in
the movie and the book and it they're
important because when we're thinking
about the problem facing our society
right now you know one one solution we
tend to hold on to and we tend to focus
education okay like okay democracy needs
education and it's true it does but then
the question is well education to what
end what what what are people what are
the lessons people are being taught
about democracy and so by going to this
this public school in inner-city Miami
and so I spoke with kids who were you
know they're like middle school age so
maybe they're 11 through 13 or 14 and
what you see is that there they are
being taught lessons about democracy but
they're very dispiriting ones they're
essentially there's kind of hidden
curriculum right that's not hidden to
them I guess because they're they're
they're gleaning its messages but
basically they're being taught to grin
and bear it
their place in the world yeah they're
being taught their place in the world so
you know what I the the thing about the
vending machine comes up because I asked
them what they would change about their
school and they say well what they
really like is for their food to be hot
like it doesn't taste good but at least
they could be warmed up and then the
administrators come down on them just
asking you so much it says unbelievable
they I mean it's just such a reasonable
demand that they have right they just
want they're at their lunch to be hot
then the vending machine thing comes up
because this one girl you know and at
first you think oh god right should kids
be eating junk food at their school but
then what you realize is she's saying it
she's saying the kids don't have
breakfast at home that's their only
chance to eat and so these kids are very
astute they're so young the various
student no what I was struck by is that
they don't blame their teachers for
their problems they have a they have an
analysis of the power structure so they
understand the teachers are controlled
by administrators who are controlled by
the state you know who also so they see
the adults is powerless so this idea
that we are the children and the parable
they it's because the children are
saying yeah we know the adults are
powerless to and so I wanted that seem
to be in the film so that we would have
to ask okay well right what kind of
education and in the book I'm able to go
more deeply into the the battle for
universal public education where that
idea even emerged so you know breaking
with the ancient Greece breaking with
the founding fathers and saying well no
we can't just have you know workers who
don't get time who don't get time to
feed their minds and and be full people
and and in the book I show that you know
working-class movements have always been
at the cutting edge for the demand for
for for not just skills training but for
education to be you know a whole
thinking participant in public life and
sort of giving the the people who don't
usually get credit the credit I think
they deserve looking back historically
and there's this wonderful other
powerful scene in the film where you're
interviewing the barber who is an ex-con
who explains I forget what was his name
le Bret le Bret and he explains when he
was in prison he's still a very young
guy they the the punishment for them
misbehaving was that their library was
taken away and you know the prisoners
actually went on strikes to get their
library privileges and it was even maybe
overly on the nose example of the power
structures trying to keep the people
from learning things and I mean yet
preaching the converted once again I
certainly think that even though I would
love I don't have a lot of data about
this I would love to see some more
social science research but I
this feeling that the more educated we
make people the better off the world is
in some large-scale way yeah I mean you
know that when Ellie told me that story
my jaw literally dropped because there
was actually so as mm it was actually
2016 and the no end of 2015 when I
interviewed with him and you know I
thought I knew a lot about criminal
justice and what people go through but
just the fact that he had to be part of
a circle for something so basic as the
right to read right yeah and then it was
very interesting because when the film
was released it premiered at the Toronto
International Film Festival and there
was a wave of prison strikes happening
around North America and there was
actually a strike in Nova Scotia Canada
and the demands of the prisoners there
was we want the library they've taken
the library away and this only makes
sense I mean if you look back on history
that this happened you know he says you
know it used to be illegal for people
like me black people to read you know
and it was a crime to teach a slave how
to read I was just reading a history of
the labor room in the u.s. books and
reading materials magazines used to be
banned from factories you know and it
wasn't it was it was not because they
didn't want people to think it was that
they didn't want people reading engaging
in a life of the mind
so I think the thing is that you know
there is something very threatening
about an educated public and I think
that that feeds into the attacks on
public education and higher education
today in this country and and and so you
know we're still you know history is not
behind us we're still part of this
struggle and so the film aims to sort of
give that sense of urgency of just how
how unjust things are right when when
kids and even adults are having to fight
just for basic basic access to materials
to dig into to you know having what they
need to learn but then also saying what
does that actually what does that say
about the the broader the broader
structure and and what does that say
about those of us for whom the edge
system has basically kind of worked out
right yeah well something I've railed
about for a long time - no and
whatsoever is just this weird idea we
have in the US that we fund public
education through local property taxes
right so it's sort of the most obvious
way that the rich can get richer and the
poor can get poorer right it's I see no
justification on the surface for
thinking that if you were born into a
wealthy family your public schools could
be better I mean not only could you
afford to go to private schools but if
you just happen to be born into a really
poor neighborhood then you're gonna get
less resources from the start feel like
this definitely fails a John Rawls and
test oh yes right totally fails and
Rawls Ian kind of like well how what
kind of you didn't know what zip code
you were gonna be into born into would
you accept this as a principle for
funding K through 12 education right no
way in the original position will never
accept this right it's a phrase every
time position would never make a right
this makes this makes a it makes a farce
out of the idea of Education but you
know as I point on the book you know
education is not a right it's not in the
Bill of Rights I mean it's something you
know when we think about what our
democracy is and these values that might
be attached to it I think education is a
good one it just like we said political
equality feels required a baseline of
economic equality while also the
baseline of education so you know I
think that that that's that in theory
should be all right but it's not a right
on paper in this world yeah I mean and
maybe it's I think it's in human rights
law but not not nationally and that's
something we almost forget because it uh
feels like a Shibboleth or something
like that
well yeah but I equalizing funding for K
through 12 education I think would be
such a rational first step of it
education reform yeah all right
well but when they they elect us to be
the dictators of the world the
benevolent dictators let us let us yeah
make it clear yeah I mean I have a more
you know but I have a very odd
educational background because I was
unschooled so I didn't go to school as a
kid and I think that that that you know
to me I feel like we have to the horizon
the Democratic horizon in terms of
education and in creating this
philosophical public that I
I believe could be you know is I think
involves you know working with the
system as it is and imagining how to
expand it and fulfill its promise you
know but but then I also think about
what could go beyond that right so um so
you know I I when I was a kid I didn't
go to school the idea was a very sort of
we're selling a romantic idea my parents
thought human beings are naturally
curious and so instead of giving carrots
and sticks and grades and yeah tests and
stuff just let let your kids do what to
follow their curiosity and so I I don't
think that scales and I really do
obviously as we've discussed believe in
public education but there's something
for me the next level would be expanding
more of that trust the trust of okay
letting people get in touch with what
their interests are and I think that
because I think I think that trust is
actually really essential to democracy
because it's again is this idea that
we're gonna rule ourselves so you know
that that makes no sense if you actually
don't have some trust in other people so
I like you know it's like what would
come next if we could just you know make
sure every kid had access to a decent
school and a hot lunch yeah and you know
the supplies they need what would come
after that ya know I think well there's
a really deep question here that I don't
think that we ever that I don't hear
much discussion about on the one hand I
think that you know among the choices
one as a responsible grown-up adult
should be allowed to make is I don't
want to learn anything more right I
think some of us are just naturally
gonna do it all the time right and
that's it's fun as part of who we are I
don't want to force it on anybody right
if it that's I'm a big believer that we
intellectuals need to do a better job of
appreciating the simple pleasures of
people who are not interested in the
kinds of things we're interested that's
okay but when you're a kid I would
almost be on the flip side of that I
mean it worked out great for you
previous mindscape cast Malcolm McIver
also was a Canadian and self schooled I
don't know maybe there's some connection
there yeah and he turned out really
really well professor at Northwestern
etc
but I I can imagine plenty of kids for
whom that would not work so I do believe
that there should be some minimal
requirements out there where you know
when you're when you're below a certain
age you got to go to school
you got to teach us some stuff I mean I
remember my love for philosophy only
came about because it was required
courses when I was an undergraduate
right I had no idea that I would be
interested in that and I was forced into
it and I fell in love no one I said I
mean I I I've had that experience to
where I had to take something and then I
was like you know my mind was blown by
it and it's not something I would have
found found before so I think again it's
this thing like how do you find that
balance of sort of giving I write this
in the book but I think one thing that
the unschooling experience gave me and
again it's sort of this thing how do you
institutionalize it was I I came to
really respect other people's
intellectual authority because they knew
things I wanted to learn right and and
so I didn't engage because I didn't have
a teacher right I wasn't sort of afraid
of teachers I wasn't afraid of being
punished or afraid of detention and or
afraid of doing badly on or getting in
trouble somehow so I think there I think
there is somehow a way to square this
circle and to cultivate a space where
people we're learning just a more
positive experience too and and where
where the the person introducing you to
an academic discipline for the first
time isn't also like really they're also
just like this figure who's disciplining
you yeah no way so but you see with
these kids in that in the scene and the
film is that you know they've got these
like harried teachers or you probably
have a classroom a forty students don't
have the resources that they need and so
there's not there isn't the space there
just isn't the capacity to have that
sort of you know that experience of
really learning and having that that
that that introduction to a to a topic
that's that really compels them you know
and I don't know so but but Who I am and
how I push the world is so shaped by my
very eccentric upper have you seen
did you watch the wire the TV show no I
haven't seen season four of the wires
and
to convince you to despair of any
possibility of public education as it is
currently constituted but we would like
to do better yeah you know and and I
think that a big part of I mean science
in particular what you just said
resonates extremely strongly the idea
that the way that we do teach science is
here are some facts you should learn
them and then tell them back to us on
the test the way that we do science is a
constant series of failures right of
making proposals hypotheses testing them
they were wrong go back and forth and
that simple paradigm is very helpful
even if you're not doing science it's a
way of looking at the world that doesn't
come across in education and that's
partly because the teachers are not
really scientists they're not taught
that way partly because they're harried
and they don't have enough resources and
they have too many kids and certainly
for you know for a lot of I've met
substitute teachers and who worked in
really bad school districts and
literally more than one person
independently volunteered the the goal
is to have no one die when they're there
right that it's not about the life of
the mind it's about just the physical
integrity of the students in their class
and just like in the richest country in
the world we can do better yes you would
like to think that okay to switch gears
a little bit cuz yeah you said something
very important very provocative and that
I've written down here we haven't got a
chance to get back to but the existence
of structures within the democratic
process within government that are
anti-democratic or at least contra
democratic the Supreme Court the Senate
the Electoral College all of these
things that prevent the democracy from
being the unfiltered will of the people
and I'm a big believer in not having the
unfiltered will of the people do
everything as someone who lives in
California and the subject to these
weird ballot initiatives that I think
are a terrible idea but there's
trade-offs right you know in some sense
the minority that is being protected by
the Senate and the Supreme Court right
now or not the minorities that deserve
protection the most so do you have you
have either feelings about that or
something more programmatic about what
we should do about that to be more
healthy democracy yeah I mean it's
interesting I think you just said
something that's quite
key right which minorities are being
protected by these institutions and so
we when we talk about minority rights we
often think at least you know I'm
speaking as a liberal person here
protections of women even though we're
not really fine or he we're just a
minority in positions of power and
influence but probably discriminated
against groups right additionally
discriminated against groups right they
disabled sexual minorities you know and
and but we have to remember is that the
minorities that the founders of our
political system had in mind it was it
was different I mean they were thinking
about religiously oppressed groups in
some cases but they were also thinking
about the opulent
the rich right I mean in this they were
very direct about this and so another
minimal definition of democracy that I
think is great is from Aristotle who
also was not a Democrat but he said so
classically in political philosophy you
know there's different systems are
organized you know they say okay well
there is the rule of the one right which
is the monarchy or the rule of the many
is oligarchy and the rule of the many is
democracy and Plato I mean sorry and
Aristotle takes that he sort of says
well yes so democracies rule of the many
but even more significantly than that
it's ruled the poor because the poor
always numerically outnumber the rich
and so the people who created our
political system were very aware of that
they had studied their ancient their
ancient Greece and they understood that
they wanted to protect minorities and
you know as someone who so in my own
personal organizing I organized
something called the debt collective
which is a union for for debtors so we
focus a lot around issues of student
debt and fighting student debt so you
know James Madison was very clear that
you need to protect the minority and
against the wicked projects of the
majority and one of the wicked projects
would be dead abolition so I mean I
think we have to you know in the book so
each chapter in the book is a is
attention that I think we have to hold
so this tension of inclusion or
exclusion and the tension between
expertise and mass opinion and then
there's the tension between one chapters
spontaneity and structure this question
you know how do we structure our our
democracy and and you know these these
structures even if you look at 200 year
history of the u.s. I mean these
institutions they were designed to
protect an affluent minority and yet
they played different roles depending on
the historical juncture so you know
there were periods when the Supreme
Court was very reactionary I mean look
at decisions like Plessy versus Ferguson
when it was standing in the way of
racial progress but then there was the
sort of you know heyday of the of the
1960s when we you know and we still you
know hold up decisions like Brown versus
BOE and now we're I think we're moving
into a very different political
alignment with the Supreme Court so you
know I think this is where your abstract
philosophical models just think can't be
to have a salute yeah because politics
is messing it depends on the power
dynamics in the in the here and now I
think we do we need to see these
structures at least this is me putting
less my philosopher Adam where my
organizer hat but we need to see these
structures as malleable they might be
really really hard to change but they
are changeable they have changed really
recently I mean if you things that we
take for granted like direct
representers I mean that was a
constitutional amendment if we can see
examples of I mean there have been I
mean the Voting Rights Act was 19 you
know it's like the mid six-nine
been tried this democracy thing by our
current minimal definition you know and
so I think I so I think we need to to
cede these things as changeable so
there's a phrase you said actually that
I want to go back to so use it well
democracy is one-person one-vote right
that is something there said yes right
that's just that sounds that sounds true
very new principle that principle is
also from Supreme Court I mean it made
its way
Supreme Court jurisprudence in I think
1963 so it was said by John Lewis during
the famous march on Washington right
said by John Lewis and he said you know
one person one vote and he actually said
one person one vote he said it because
hey America was not doing it because of
segregation and Jim Crow constraints
that were basically totally suppressing
the vote of black people in the south
but he said one person one vote is the
African cry and it should be our cry -
why did he say that he said it because
it was actually a phrase that was being
promoted by the ancien South Africa and
Nelson Mandela so you know these at that
point they were these South African
Marxist right yeah and now here we are
this this beautiful phrase this
beautiful ideal comes from South Africa
through the civil rights movement now we
take it for granted like oh yeah one
person one vote that just makes sense
well no it's really new and the question
I think we have to ask ourselves now is
is it even democratic so a we don't have
it because people are disenfranchised
felons are disenfranchised and not given
the right to vote but okay so you can
have one vote you can access the ballot
but what if your votes not weighted
equally right which it's not in our city
in our in our society the Senate for
example or because of the electoral
college you mean because of the
electoral college or because of the way
districts are apportioned you've been at
the state level so you know you can have
within the state your your vote for a
member of Congress can be way more or
less than someone a few counties away so
the Senate right if every state gets the
same number of senators but you have a
state that's you know a couple million
people versus California where you are
like you're a Senate vote weighs almost
nothing so I would say why don't we
expand the idea of one person one vote
stay one person one equally weighted
vote and then I but then I would say
that doesn't even go far enough we could
actually push for one person three votes
or four votes through something like
rank-choice voting right where you would
no longer have to worry about splitting
your vote let's say you know and ending
up with a split ticket where your
you cast a ballot but it actually helps
elect the person you like the least
so there's rank choice voting is now
happening in Maine it's happening in a
little community in in Michigan I think
Massachusetts is adopting it right so
people actually have three votes and
they get the ranked first preference
second preference in the book I also
point out well what about the principle
one person no vote because what if we
abandoned elections entirely and use
sortition so I think I'm just going
through these are the ways that what is
for titian lottery oh okay yes I gotta
know what if we yeah what if we so they
to go back to Athens again you know they
they thought elections were aristocratic
because the rich and the well-born would
win and today we might say it's a
reality TV stars but you know that that
actually it was it was a contest that
just reinforced privilege so they had
very elaborate systems of randomly
selecting citizens and engaging the
public in the running of the city's
affairs and so you know again to quote
Aristotle he said you know I elections
are aristocratic and selection is
democratic and I think it's quite it's
quite an interesting you know it's a
it's a thought experiment effectively in
the United States today but to say okay
well our elections especially as they're
currently run are they are they really
democratic and so yeah maybe one-person
one-vote is holding us back maybe one
person no vote and happy thinking about
doing it using quantum measurements so
that there are different branches of the
wavefunction with completely different
rulers in every branch that would be
amazing okay so that is the next level
galaxies brain again bring it back to
bring it to earth brain I'm sure you saw
the news that Ireland by referendum
actually decided they would amend their
constitution and open the way to allow
abortion right yeah so this seems like a
very intractable like just one of those
political issues I mean we're talking
about this Catholic country how would
that ever get resolved why the vote went
the way did
and had so much democratic legitimacy
was in part because the country was at
this breaking point so they used
sortition they used lottery so what they
did was they created the citizens
assembly and selected 99 citizens at
random who sort of were representative
in quotes of the of the nation and they
deliberated for five months I did not
know well yeah and then they come at
came up with with recommendations and
they said hey we've really thought about
this and we've talked to all these
experts and we really think actually the
Constitution is antiquated and should be
reassessed and that gave the sense of
democratic legitimacy that would have
been missing and otherwise it would have
just been this very destructive vote
kind of like these other referendums
we've seen but instead they use lottery
in a way that kind of allowed there to
be a sense that the people of Ireland
had sought together and and been heard
and and the the citizens assembly didn't
have power they didn't then make a
determination they made a recommendation
that was listen to I think yeah interest
I just think you know the point is we
have to remember that that these are
malleable these are malleable structures
human made them human human beings made
them and and they can be changed and you
know history shows that they can often
let me change with real struggle shorter
that's that's a tactical issue that's a
strategic issue but you know we
shouldn't we we should not buy into the
myth that what we have is democracy and
this is the be-all and end-all no not at
all and I think that you know the
lottery idea would probably be laughed
out of court in a lot of parts of the
United States but I get it I get the the
sense that it's much more democratic
because there's not all of these layers
of filters of political advertising and
you know you need to be a millionaire to
run for office and and stuff like that
you know I be ten that I just had this
thought over the course of this
conversation but I'm completely on board
with having a third chamber of Congress
which is just randomly selected people
from the United States exactly so i i i
think you've honed in on exactly how one
has to approach it it's you know how do
you put it into
the mix with other other methods and
other approaches of doing democracy you
know I'm it's not this is about finding
the new religion and being like I'm for
lottery to solve all of our problems all
the time but you know actually given the
the problems with the system that we
have right now which is you know who has
the capacity to run for office what are
the incentives and how much money do
they have to raise and then well what
are they thinking about when they're
they're serving when they're serving as
public officials they're thinking about
reelection right so you know if there
was another house that was the people's
the people's house that was where
citizens were called up you know at
random you know they'd have they'd have
a whole different set of concerns and
all sorts of political scientists have
done research about how to reduce
corruption of this this hypothetical
body and how when would educate educate
these citizen leaders about issues so
there's actually all sorts of really
interesting work in the again we can
point to the example of Ireland but you
know I think it's you know what one
trick isn't gonna save us not sure but
it because think in a different way it
is an outside-the-box thing and they're
there there are issues with the current
system and thinking outside the box is a
good thing if there's so many things I
want to talk about but the one that is
major and we need to get to is the idea
that a democracy on the one hand it's
the people's will is legitimizing the
government on the other hand there is
this agreement on the part of the people
to abide by what happens right whether
you want to call it norms or a
commitment to pluralism or value
diversity or whatever number one is this
good and number two is it tenable like
are we seeing that people these days are
less willing to put up with what is what
other people are deciding for them the
coercion part of your interesting I mean
I I think I was talking to this woman
who is a civil rights lawyer in North
Carolina and she said something that
really resonated with me and she said
you know I don't know why it is that
it's so hard to build things it's so
hard to create constructive institutions
and fair rules and yet it's so easy to
destroy it's so easy for things to fall
it's the second law of thermodynamics we
know why that's true entropy is entropy
yet it increases yeah I mean it's it's
funny so I was thinking about that as I
read your great book on time and I was
like entropy that there needs to be a
political theory of entropy because and
so I think because of this and let's
let's just say it's a lot of the
universe that gives us authority because
of this we have to we have to try to
value the norms you have to we have to
fight for them and we have to fight to
make norms more just and and so you know
as as a woman you know but I think as a
citizen we should all be able to say hey
norms have actually been really terrible
no norms can be right they can be really
regressive they can be dehumanizing all
sorts of terrible things have been legal
and are illegal slavery was legal you
know and right now they're fighting you
know we're living in a world where
they're they're fighting to make you
know destroying the environment and
poisoning the population legal so so we
don't want to fetishize rules for their
own sake but I just I do think we want
to be attuned to the fact that yeah it's
very difficult it's very difficult to
build things and entropy will get us and
I think you do see I mean I don't think
we're at a point where the American
people are just like total nihilist
maybe that's the momentum I don't know
yeah but I think okay so this is again
I'm gonna put on my organizer hat yeah
when the rules of the game are so
corrupt people are frustrated and and I
think I think cynicism is really toxic
for a democracy I mean I think this is
you know the legacy of even like the
Watergate era right it was not good for
for the project of people coming
together and and wanting to build a
better government actually it made it
did helped lay this groundwork of people
just being really cynical about about
the the power structures but that
cynicism is merited and and so for me
when I try to engage people and my
instinct isn't you know you can't you
can't tell people like oh no it's
actually really great we're the greatest
country on earth and everything works
you know I think you have to say yeah
you know this right now we do have a
system where you know the members of
Congress are mostly millionaires and you
know indeed there is a system of
legalized bribery that we call campaign
donations and lobbying at work but you
know we have to speak to people's and we
have to speak to people's cynicism and
their despair and try to build a
coalition that and give them credible
alternatives and and build a social
block that will push for for real change
so I think you know when we when we see
this volatility it's tempting to kind of
be afraid of it or you know and I don't
know I guess for me I'm like well no we
have to we have to kind of throw
ourselves into it and speak to it and in
create solidarity and create strategies
that can be a path a path forward and
it's that that's the hard work of of
organizing that's not really the work of
philosophizing and you have to speak to
people's this is the cliche of community
organizing 101 but you have to speak to
people's real direct needs and income in
and and try to find a sort of win-win
solution out of the mess right and it's
a balancing act right we don't want to
overthrow everything every twenty years
as Jefferson
somewhat yeah somewhat playfully
suggested but the norms do matter
because there's a protective aspect to
them but there's also a
anti-progress aspect to them I do think
by the way parenthetically that there
probably is a very good analogy to be
drawn between the body politic and real
biological bodies when it comes to
entropy and organization in homeostasis
you know we the our bodies would left to
their own devices just decay we would
die but instead we take in fuel and we
use that to upkeep and maintain
ourselves and there
is some work that is necessary to make
that happen and I'm sure the same thing
is true for a society or a government
what's interesting I was talking to a
political theorist the other day about
this metaphor of the social body because
it comes into my film so the film begins
with I'm sitting with Silvia Federici in
a museum and we're looking at a painting
and we talk about this image in front of
us it's it's a it's a image of a vice
but of a it's in viens she's sign and we
talk about how the social body is being
sawed apart right now and social body is
this metaphor that is constant in
political philosophy and body politic
and it has it can often have almost
fascist undertones or even overtones
right because people start to go like
okay they start to have this kind of
ethno nationalist body right they keep
keep the foreigners obey and so our
point in our conversation was like well
hold on but let's actually be more
biological about it like no body is an
island in isolation all bodies are
permeable we have our microbiomes and we
have to eat as you just said and so you
know where is this myth of this body
that is autonomous and independent and
cut off from the den doesn't generate
other bodies another other you know
human beings so it's like let's let's
actually embrace that permeability and
yeah we're the quintessential open
systems and we can yeah you know eat
well or eat badly we can exercise or sit
around and and I think the allergy is
actually pretty good and there's there's
physics underlying all of it as you will
not be surprised to learn and one of the
aspects there is that with bodies either
literal or political the environment
that we're embedded in is changing right
Darwinian evolution never stops working
but the pressures that push us one way
or the other
are different depending are on our
environments when it comes to politics
you know where technology is changing
things very rapidly right we have
different media that teach us things is
that something again I'll just ask these
open-ended question you know are you
given social media and cable news and
talk radio and whatever how do you
balance whether this is good or bad and
how can we use it as a force for better
yeah well for on the social media
question I was I would say everyone
should just read my book the people's
platform which came out in 2014 and and
the people's platform is my analysis of
of social media was came out at a time
where people were a bit more techno
utopian than they are today but I think
my basic argument sale holds which is we
can't separate the technology from the
business models underlying it and
specifically from the business model of
advertising and data collection and so
the internet not intrinsically but just
because this is sort of I think just the
the way our media landscape works I mean
it was just how it was television also
ran on a that's right so did newspapers
and now now the sort of gloves are off
for data collection and personalized you
know behavioural targeting and all of
this stuff and so my blog will well my
podcast will be taking ads but they're
not targeted in companies I'm happiest
shilling for basically like I get to
veto places that I'm not interested I've
already gotten well I think many details
but people asked me for to advertise on
the podcast and I looked at what they're
selling I'm like no I can't do that well
I mean and then you know and the thing
is we are where we're all and embroiled
in this system and part of the point I'm
trying to make too is that this isn't
sort of you know I mean I fired a
podcast and I would also veto ads and
you know maybe consider taking others
but the point is that you know we're
we're all in an advertising economy
whether we want to or not because we're
being offered you know ostensibly free
services but actually we're paying with
our personal data so I think they have
to be attuned to the way that this
business model is creating the kind of
clickbait economy right that we are
seeing and that is very detrimental for
a deliberation and debate because
ultimately if what what the platform is
more interested in serving you a bunch
of headlines that you're just gonna like
look at and get to the next one as
opposed to in being incentivized to said
give you a long I mean the fact we even
have the word long read yeah the time
but you know it they'd rather have me
click a lot than have me
read something that takes an hour and so
that's you know you know it's
interesting cuz we kind of say like oh
it's so hard to read something long
online well is it necessarily or is it
because actually all of the research has
been geared towards pushing us in the
opposite direction I mean there's a
quote in my in the people's platform is
like the greatest minds of my generation
are all just figuring out how to make
people click on ads so so I I you know
so on the one hand obviously there's a
human temperament to be distracted and
to believe falsehoods this is why in the
Republic Plato is basically talking
about the fake news of his day right
again democracy mm-hmm
it doesn't elevate the wise people
people believe believe lies they gossip
they're misguided but unfortunately we
have this whole technological apparatus
that because it's priorities are
accumulating profits through data
collection are really antithetical to
our needs as citizens and human beings
and you know it is basically the you
know it's a continuation of the
television model I mean there's a reason
that the former head of CBS said you
know yeah Trump's not good for America
but he sure is good for business right
so I mean the implication seems to be
that we have vigilance and take active
steps to make sure that this doesn't
trample us underfoot in some sense yeah
I think though you know this is where
you know it's it's it's the economy
stupid it's like you know we we have to
I think it's it's a really daunting task
but like what what are the how do we
transform the the underlying incentives
that are shaking that are shaping our
media center right I mean this is you
know we see this I work in the education
space and I see the difference between
you know people who go to a traditional
four-year public college or people who
go to a predatory for-profit college
right there's a difference and right now
there's almost no public media in the
United States of America it's just not
something that existed in and you know
and and there is no sort of intrinsic
reason why we can't experiment with
other modes of subsidy online I mean in
fact the internet was a non-commercial
you know was a non-commercial academic
invention big business didn't give us
the internet or the World Wide Web so
you know and this is why you know there
are lots of people who are kind of
nostalgic for the early the early days
of the internet before it was fully
commercialized but I think you know so I
I think we have to it's very heartening
to me that people are finally having
conversations about sort of breaking up
big tech but I think we need to go a
step further and go okay what other ways
could we fund things that aren't just
the sort of advertising or patreon you
know donation models yeah but you know
I'm a Canadian in fact what is democracy
was funded by the National Film Board of
Canada and so I you know I in this is an
anecdote I often give but in 2014 I went
to my New York City literary agent you
know I have a very good liar agent and a
fancy agency and I said I want to write
a book on democracy and she said no way
that is a career suicide it will never
sell then I went to the National Film
Board of Canada said I want to make a
movie about democracy which I think it
should be harder that sounds like a
harder sell yeah I'm right for right and
they were like that's great that's you
know exactly what we're here for to spur
public debate about interesting things
and so you know I couldn't get a
democracy project off the ground until
after Donald Trump was elected and then
everybody um was like well maybe we
should think about this word but I think
it said something about why we're in the
mess we're in
and also about funding structures that
can hold different kinds of work and
different kinds of thinking so that
suggests that so the final question that
you're suggesting an answer to it
already but what makes you optimistic
what are the things we can do to I take
it that we're both on the side that
democracy is a good thing but it can be
a flawed thing and it is like the body
it's an open system that needs constant
care and maintenance and an improvement
so where do you see that coming from I
see hope in the attitudes of young
people right now and and I'm someone
who's so against fetishizing young
people yes you know this sort of
you know because I think we need a we
need public engagement from people of
all ages and backgrounds and so um you
know in fact when I was in my 20s I used
to joke that in its opposition to the
baby boomers I was like it's not don't
trust anyone it's not it's not that you
shouldn't trust people over under I'm
sorry the baby boomers are basically
like don't trust anyone over 30 right
you know like only the youth get it told
ya my attitude was like no you shouldn't
trust people until they're over 30 these
ideas um but I think you see I mean we
see people this is a generation that has
every reason on some of the just be
totally disgusted totally cynical right
I mean look at the person who occupies
the White House look at what's happening
with climate change I mean people have
known about climate change scientists
have known about climate change the
leaders of the most powerful
corporations on earth leaders and
government have known since long before
these kids were born and they chose to
suppress it and deny it and actively
subsidize these industries and yet so
they should have every reasons just be
completely disgusted and yet here they
are you know it's striking for the
climate going out week after week they
are you know pushing for for gun control
we see this wave of really idealistic
people in their late 20s and early 30s
running for office you know and this is
a market shift because you know I was
you know part of Occupy Wall Street that
was only 2011 and the attitude there was
no way no engaging with the system on
that level we refused to even make
demands government right and we can
debate the pros and cons of that and and
we can debate this sort of you know the
purpose occupy served because I think it
was it was I think it was important even
if it was ineffectual in many ways but
you know I'm happy to see people going
beyond that and saying no we're willing
to get our hands dirty and step into the
fray because you know we have 11 years
and
gonna lose and if we don't do it nobody
will so that um I I never have trouble
finding hope I've almost find
hopelessness to be kind of trite because
I think if you have a historical gaze
it's impossible to deny the fact that
people have had it so much harder than
us yeah you know so then it's like well
you know here we are talking on skype
yes squad cast sorry go I mean you know
and and you know yeah just have some
have some perspective you know it's it's
been worse it's been worse and um and
you know and in the book system like you
know let's let's try to be good
ancestors let's try to be the people we
would respect if we were looking back
you know it doesn't mean that we have to
win but we have to try yeah I mean in
clickbait ii media landscape
notwithstanding i get some optimism from
the fact that remarkable number of
people are interested in listening to
our long conversations about the nature
of democracies i think they are no easy
answers but i think you know the book
ends with this image of you know let's
let's not aspire to be founding fathers
but perennial midwife's like this is
something we just have to do over and
over and over again and and what what it
means to get involved in you know in
enlarging democracy deepening democracy
it really does depend on where you are
in your community and what the people
around you care about you know there is
sure we can say easy things like go vote
or something like that but but that
should take you know an hour of your
time yeah the other questions you know
have they have a lot of specificity and
and we have to and they're not questions
we can answer by ourselves so and that's
hard at the right way to think of this
Jeffersonian impulse that not to throw
overthrow the government every 20 years
but to continually renew it by actually
engaging with it I think that that I
think there is I agree with you the
historical view gives us actually
believe it or not some source of
optimism oh yeah no you know things
would be bad things are bad they were
worse and they couldn't get hurt but
only if we do it they don't doesn't
happen automatically right yeah and
things could be better so I think this
is you know it's always I
I always recommend studying social
movements and and thinking about all the
all the work that has done to get us
where we are today so let's keep going
all right let's keep going
Esther Taylor thanks so much for being
on the podcast hey thanks for having me
it was really fun
[Music]